bonjour à vingt bons jours alors on va
pas dire qui vous êtes tout le monde le
sait
10h10 triano wii est de même de marquer
aussi loué à un domaine trop peu connu à
mon énergie c'est parce que c'est un
domaine ne reste pas grand chose si ce
n'est une âme est ce que j'aime dans un
jardin c'est justement la mpt de l'âme
du lieu l'âme ne raconte tellement de
choses que j'aime bien cette idée des
fois de jardin à peu l'agent la fortwo
mais on va parler de l'âme alors là on
est un peu ici chez vous parce que vous
habitez vous travaille ici depuis
combien ça fait 30 ans je suis entré en
1976 vous avez tellement j'étais plus
jeune j'étais petit je suis en passe
d'être cassé à mon tour monuments
historiques mais donc je suis rentré ici
comme gamin effectivement stagiaires
comme stagiaire comme pc puis je suis
jamais en chef depuis 1981 2,82 et
j'essaie avec mes collaborateurs
d'entretenir au mieux ce parc vaste car
il est quand même grand de 850 hectares
ce n'est pas rien 43 kilomètres d'allées
un jardin à la française et ce jardin et
ce jardin paysager qui est un lieu que
j'aime particulièrement alors où est ce
qu'on est ici alors on a eu un mot de la
reine on est à peu près à 500 mètres du
petit trianon qui était la résidence
construite pour louer 15 et que marie
antoinette plus tard va s'approprier
pour avril à environ deux kilomètres du
château le grand bazar comme dirait jean
pierre coffe qui est un habitué des
lieux qui est un habitué des lieux et
qui vous avez beaucoup beaucoup
travaillé c'est quoi le le le le métier
des jardiniers
c'est un métier qui est simple en fait
mon métier consiste à entretenir au
mieux ce domaine qui m'a été légué
entretenu par le pal par les anciens
j'aime cette ambiance si on alors parler
cru mais je trouve qu'il ya beaucoup de
respect dans cette appellation donc je
mens mon rôle est d'entretenir au mieux
le domaine et de le transmettre aux
générations futures dans le même état
voit dans meilleur état que moi même
j'en ai hérité donc c'est un métier de
transmission d'embellissement et
d'entretien on peut le transformer un
peu ou pas on peut le transformer parce
que malheureusement certains de mes
prédécesseurs n'ont pas toujours eu
beaucoup de boue il faut le reconnaître
a eu tout juste un exemple et si nous
sommes dans un espace champêtre et le
dessinateur de marie-antoinette richard
mique avait pris soin de créer de vastes
clairière qui fait la beauté de la
clairière justement ce qui est pas
d'armes et jardinier dans les années
1920 ou 30 celui ci vise à cette grande
pomme sans arbres oui on va par exemple
pour remettre des déclare donc je ne
vais pas embellir par rapport aux
créateurs du lieu qui serait prétentieux
mais je vais embellir par rapport à
quelle saison elle près du cfl avait
donc oui on peut améliorer la
présentation du site parler du créateur
du lieu est donc c'est le nôtre 400e
anniversaire on va donc on va fêter en
2013 vous en vous a parlé un petit peu
dans ce no 7 dans mon agenda du jardin
qui vient pas aux éditions flammarion
vous dites aux fausses et s en sa
qualité de notre principal c'était la
lenteur oui d'ailleurs été assez amusant
quand le nôtre devait être enfin fait
noble riz par l'intérieur il aura fallu
du temps 1 et bien le 14 de monde à le
nôtre ce qu'il souhaite voir mise sur
ses armoiries le nôtre réfléchi et le
dit majesté vous m'avez toujours
reproché d'être lent aller parce que
j'étais impatient immigration c'est la
nature qui commandait le nôtre le
rappeler c'est la nature qui commande et
bien le nôtre va demander à ce qu'on
mette des limaces on est sur les armes
officiel de le nôtre il ya trois
animations pour rappeler que la nature
prend son temps et qu'il faut la suivre
il faut du temps versez est un lieu où
nous produisons de manière bio
écologiques alors ça c'est grâce à vous
en particulier en faveur non non je suis
l'un de ceux qui a initié ce mouvement
je ne suis pas le seul pesticides
on respecte on respecter les saisons il
par exemple donc oui je fais partie de
ceux qui pensent qu'aujourd'hui un
domaine comme celui ci doit être
exemplaire versailles est un lieu
extraordinaire pour son histoire pour
les artistes qui s'y sont succédé pour
la littérature la sculpture à la
peinture ça quand même le comble que les
jardins eux aussi ne donne pas l'exemple
donc on se veut d'être exemplaire au
même titre que les autres disciplines
que je viens de citer alors qu'elle se
baladait un petit peu mais avant je
voudrais c'est quoi cette tour la balle
antonette a voulu à un petit village où
elle serait la reine la reine de son
village elle avait produit des traînes
de france mais si elle était heureuse
elle avait construit ce fait construire
par l'architecte richard mique ce petit
bâtiment avec en dessous l'atout à la
pêcherie cas on aimait beaucoup péché
oui on peut empêcher les cartes rihanna
pour la petite anecdote les carpes quel
péché était servi à table et on disait
car peu de la reine et tout le monde
était admiratif de la 2de de devenir
goût et de la saveur
je pense qu'on était dans la flagornerie
la cour quand même et au dessous ou au
dessus de la de la salle de pêche la
tour de guet c'était amusant de voir de
temps en temps si leur arrivée ou pas
mais les enfants de marionnettes
découvrant cette tour chante la chanson
connue malbrouck 120
ils ont donc fait la tour de malbrouck
c'est devenu
hélas
alors là nous avons le colombier donc il
y avait des colombes un petit peu plus
loin il y avait la maison du jardinier
ou la maison du garde et puis et puis
derrière là juste là la maison de la
reine qui est en fait composé en deux
parts et à droite la maison de la reine
et elle est plus grande que la partie de
gauche qui est réservé aux seigneurs qui
a imaginé le scandale on a parti de la
reine est plus grande que la partie de
la monnaie et ben oui tout à fait on en
1783 ça ne plaît pas à tout le monde les
ennuis le temps groupe et alors là il ya
un petit passage c'est ça je vois vous
êtes bien renseigné
si vous avez
une vraie et fausse cave est en fait il
ya une vraie cave où l'on pouvait faire
séjourner quelques vins de qualité et un
souterrain qui permet de rentrer et de
sortir wolof sans être vus il faut
savoir que toute cette partie est
entouré d'un gigantesque fosse et on ne
prépare pas ibérique pas on a des postes
de garde obligatoires à franchir sauf si
on est un habitué des lieux et l'on sait
comment printemps le que le souterrain
par la maison paraît clave on pourra
entrer sortir sans être vu il stimule
sony que fersen mais empreinte est une
invite à rentrer pense qu'il était
l'amant de la bande à rennes l'année
donc et s'il devait venir ici et
l'emprunté de souterrains et et
pouvaient ensuite je présume aller dans
une et nombreuses pièces pour faire la
cour effrénée à sa majesté ni vu ni
connu tout à fait tout à fait
alors là on est devant les labos de la
reine dont vous parliez c'est vrai que
oui la partie de la reine plus grandes
salles bureau c'est l'homme beaucoup
plus importante maison qu'il ya beaucoup
d' allure qui donne sur un lac bien
évidemment à vue et sublime la vie y est
sublime art sur la gauche a le petit
moulin est ce qu'il faut et de
l'animation et puis sur la droite un
seul port qui n'est pas très vieux mais
qui été replantés à l'endroit exact où
la reine elles mêmes on avait installé
un en 1786 pour célébrer la naissance de
son fils comme quoi même au 18e siècle
on pouvait déjà planté des arbres pour
commémorer la naissance à l'enfant on a
on a tous les plantes tout ça on l'a
tous les plans tous les plants étaient
conservés on a tous les documents on a
même des documents très drôle le lieu se
veut anglais nous sommes dans un jardin
anglais autonet venons 15 janvier
anglais elle est persuadée que j'allais
me on va donc trouver un gamin en grec
est vraiment une compétence sera un
mondial à rennes attention c'est un
coureur de jupons ça ne m'intéresse pas
ce qu'elle veut c'est un professionnel
donc il est recruté et on sait de
manière certaine que gamma et vire au
bout de quelques mois non pas qu'il est
incompétent mais il a contaminé toutes
les jeunes filles de la région c'était
pour toi de quelques malades y aller
voilà les deux plus dans l'est mais
c'est tout ça on sait absolument tout ça
est ce que c'est ça qui vous a fait
assez rapidement jardin de passion
l'écriture aussi si vous vouliez aller
libre oui mais c 'est c'est un ensemble
moi je suis tombé amoureux de versailles
je suis tombé amoureux des arbres de
versets qui sont aux mains d'éléments
extraordinaires et plus j'ai après une
besoin de transmettre andré le nôtre
dont on fête cette année le 400e
anniversaire de sa naissance n'a
pratiquement rien écrit n'a pratiquement
rien 3 je passe mon temps à critiquer
alors au moins 1 1 je ne suis pas sûr
l'exemple que je veux transmettre douma
passion de l'écriture alors ya donc cet
agenda dont je parle et auteur il ya des
choses très très amusant de vous dites
pour par exemple il ya une grande mode
c'est des légumes oubliés oui et vous
dites force collective oublié peut-être
une raison il fait une raison ça va
toujours turlupiner ouais c'est un
légume et et goûtent si les savoure
pouvoir garde on ne garde pas les
légumes oubliez sont comme des légumes
qui n'ont aucun intérêt c'est vrai mais
que certains grands chefs aux jeux des
biens aux nous remettre aujourd'hui sur
la tête de leur très grand restant à un
prix
complètement dément je pense à toutes
ces plantes que nos anciens ont connu
pendant la guerre oui si ça parce qu'ils
étaient des choses que moi j'ai entendu
sa part des parents
parce que ça leur a plu il n'y a pas
longtemps chez un chef étoilé rutabaga
c'est très tard
on ne s'en remet toujours pas alors il
ya aussi un coup de gueule qui paraît
début octobre chèque de sud c'est la
haine de l'arbre lan dollar n'est pas
une fatalité c'est un livre très
polémique parce que dit au fond on
n'aime pas les arbres et on voudrait le
faire quant à l'objet non le coupe quand
une voiture s'encastre compte à lens est
toujours dramatique bien évidemment mais
bon on va couper les arbres parmi par
milliers est-ce qu'on a est ce qu'on
envisagerait un instant en france de
course de démolir une cathédrale parce
qu'elle dérange est ce que cela vient à
l'esprit à quelqu'un de détruire une
fontaine parce qu'on va refaire le
trottoir non mais là on est ce qu'on va
long cou aïe à paris on va coupat
platanes à marronniers à jonathan sexton
car cet arbre coupé forgan et 12
secondes autres en eau
comment dire aux conducteurs de bus sur
un trajet estimé à 2 heures on est les
écolos ont rien dit comme souvent c'est
même là l'actuel et élus verts qui a
encouragé l'abattage une arrivée bien
évidemment et moi je me suis inspiré de
tout ce que j'ai pu lire dans la presse
la sphère du marronnier par exemple été
très largement reprises pour le journal
le monde ont accusé le monde d'être un
journal de fantaisiste je parle
également des maires des communes qui
ont décidé de couper des arbres je pense
à la commune de de chalamont de virson
chalamont il y avait 2,2 enfin il existe
toujours de fresnes puis encore une
petite chapelle 1 le maire avait décidé
de couper pour une raison et une seule
parce qu'elle avait des cds
ne sont pas dangereuses menaces pas tous
les experts disent ces armes ne pose
aucun dégât et son dos le maire a
décrété qu'il fallait les remplacer pour
une raison simple c'est qu'ils sont
appelés à mourir quand on a affaire
et donc je vais revoir dans ce livre
effectivement c'est un plaidoyer pour
tous les arbres les am ne sont pas
seulement des monuments de cv de bois
c'est l'histoire d'un pays ce sont des
souvenirs c'est aussi l'avenir de la
planète on a bien sûr il faut tout
simplement qu'aujourd'hui on les aime
peut-être un peu plus qu'on leur parle
et vous leur parlez moi je reparle alors
je vais passer une écoute mais leur
parle en fait du bien vous devriez c
j'ai essayé oui mais là et c'est vrai
qu'il ya peut-être c'est peut-être votre
plus mauvais souvenir évidemment quand
on est dans des lieux aussi idyllique
que je pense qu'on a beaucoup de très
bons souvenirs le plus mauvais ça a été
quand même la tempête de 99 euros
on dira que c'était une destruction
massive dont je parle de l'aisne de
l'arbre justement je ne dis pas qu'il ne
faut pas abattre les arbres je dis aux
contacts qu'il faut intervenir de temps
en temps c'est on nous avait écoutés
avant la tempête nous aurions couper un
grand nombre de végétaux qui en chutant
à cause des vents n'aurait pas dévasté
sur leur passage d'autres arbres bien
effectivement la tempête de 99 a causé
des dégâts considérables a versé plus de
35 mille arbres ont été détruits
arracher des races nez cassé il a fallu
replanter une quantité astronomique de
300 et darmon du tracé a été replanté
mais il est vrai que c'est à l'époque le
domaine avait été mieux gérées au niveau
des arbres y aurait peut-être une moins
de bruit moins de 2000 jeunes parce
qu'on ne voulait pas à l'époque
consacrer de l'argent simplement pour la
gestion du patrimoine arboré un arbre
c'est comme vous de temps en temps vous
avez besoin de soin de vous en
médicaments mais besoin d'une attention
et bien de temps en temps il faut
également trouver des crédits pour
entretenir les arbres
j'appelle de nos titres de ce dernier
rival il faut l'acheter parce que
voilà c'est une prise de conscience line
de l'arbre n'est pas une fatalité c'est
chez actes sud et puis villa mouvement
desjardins du jardin chez flammarion
avec des petits conseils très quotidien
aider
et nous place de stagiaire
j'ai beaucoup de demandes
parce que
envoyé mac obama je vous envoie un cv on
va y réfléchir merci merci